we will soon begin the construction of a
great great wall along our southern
border it looks quite interesting to see
that the country that grew for years
because of free trade and from receiving
immigrants now wants to raise barriers
to trade and to people
[Music]
I have Nicol SP with reason and today
we're sitting down with Gabriele Calzada
he's the president of University
Francisco marroquín a private university
in Guatemala and we're gonna talk about
higher education and also the economic
and political direction of Latin America
Gabrielle thanks so much for talking to
us it's a pleasure
you run a university in Guatemala that
was established in 1971 and it's rare
there because it's private university
what is the essential mission for higher
of higher education in the 21st century
well I think in the 21st century since
you have basically all the content in
your mobile device universities have to
move the the focus from given content
that have been doing this for many years
to creating experiences interactions we
will see a shift from grades from having
focus in the grades to have a focus in
the portfolios of experiences that you
can show the university that will
survive our universities were that will
create safe space but not safe space in
the sense that we usually here the dark
places where you have the right not to
be offended or bothered but the safe
places in the in the sense that you
create a space where students can commit
errors and can learn from those errors
without the the problems of these errors
in real life in the United States a lot
of the discussion and discourse about
higher education has to do with this
encroachment of safe spaces of political
correctness of speech codes and the
inability of faculty and students and
outside speakers who come to enrich the
environment you know are not allowed to
speak freely is is that also a problem
in Guatemala or does it take a different
form there no not at all in what Amala
students speak freely we foster we try
to foster debate we think that being
uncomfortable because of the ideas of
others is one of the experience you have
to have at the university you're opening
a campus in Spain how will that help
fulfill the the vision that you were
talking about about having a portfolio
of experiences what what will be going
on there going to a different culture
it's already a great experience but
mentally going to a place where
regulation has been going so far so that
the students can learn what are the
results of big government and then of
course we want to offer the the European
public an opportunity to have a
classical liberal libertarian education
that is currently very difficult in the
European space and I think with the UFM
experience we can offer new programs
that will be very original very
different from the type of programs that
Spaniards and Europeans are used to it
doesn't make sense to talk about a
direction for Latin America and is that
direction going in the right way or the
wrong way I mean there seem to be so
many different things so there's your
experiences in Guatemala there are
certain countries that are liberalizing
and then there are countries like
Venezuela which seems to really be in
very collapsing threat yeah I mean and
then but but then also in Brazil as well
as elsewhere you see both good things
and bad things happening at the same
time what is your sense is Latin America
which has gone through various phases of
liberalisation and then kind of
retrenchment what how are things looking
right now I think right now things are
looking pretty good though so we are
moving in the in the good direction and
you can see this in Argentina you can
see this even in Ecuador things so far
in that in the last few months seems to
be better than then they were a year ago
even if probably what we would have
lacked this is a more radical change it
didn't happen and you also see I think
I'm relatively optimistic because you
see that in the civil society more than
the governments civil society is much
more conscious of the need of creating
associations to mobilize and in a way
similar to what Tocqueville was talking
about that was necessary to to sustain
our liberties and you see this in
Ecuador you see this in in Chile and you
see this in Argentina in Bolivia you see
this everywhere you see associations
organizations many of them related to
students and using movements for in
Guatemala for example last year the new
government decided to raise taxes
they said that they were new in the
government they said well the solution
like always is to raise taxes for the
rich so we can solve the problems of the
country and suddenly you so many
students going into the streets for
students and professionals going to the
streets saying no this cannot be
solution politicians always wants to
raise taxes the solution is to to look
at the expenses of the government and
make them more rational reduce them and
so balance the budget in that way what's
the sense towards America under Donald
Trump because he is been explicitly you
know just buzina phobic towards Mexicans
for sure but he seems to have a limited
understanding or interest or engagement
with most of Central America and South
America Latin America more generally is
he seen as a good person a bad person a
good president a good friend or is is
there a clear sense of how people think
about him in Guatemala to see a
president that thinks that the US has to
raise their barriers all kind of
barriers to people to goods to services
it's a danger not just for Central
America is a danger for the US and for
the world the country that grew for
years and for centuries because of free
trade and and and and from receiving
immigrants now wants to raise barriers
to trade and and to people well we will
leave it there and hopefully I think we
agree hopefully those barriers will you
know only get to a couple inches high
because it will walk over but thanks
again and thank you for reason I'm Nick
Gillespie
[Music]
[Music]